what's going on everybody and welcome to
a new updated Python 3 basics series I'm
not really the biggest fan of the basic
series that I've done in the past
because it's not really what I suggest
you go through in the basics if you're
really just getting started and you
actually want to learn Python I think
the way that you really want to learn it
is you want to deal with the basics as
little as possible and you know learn
the things that you really need to know
and then just jump into actual projects
that you personally find interesting the
basics are boring so my hope here is to
more quickly run through the basics and
get you to the point where I actually
think you should stop with the basics so
on my old basics tutorial series I kept
telling people hey go to like part 13
out of 50 and and stop there and start
working on things that interest you so
with Python you can do a million
different things you can make websites
you can do self-driving car stuff and
machine learning and you know do
robotics and make goo ease and just all
kinds of stuff and so you don't want us
you don't need to spend time in the
basics to learn the language and the
best thing you can do is just start
working on projects so the purpose of
this tutorial is gonna be focused more
so on someone who is brand new to
programming so someone who heard gooey
and probably has no idea what that guy
was talking about so graphical user
interface I think that you know too
often we just kind of run through the
syntax of a programming or language and
we're not actually learning how to
program but also we're just kind of
checking off boxes and that's not really
the way you learn to program so I just
want to show you guys what you need and
then you can get off and do whatever the
heck you want to do from there so just
to give you sort of an idea of what all
you can do if you go to Python program
Internet you can see a bunch of options
here you can do data analysis some
robotics on web development make various
different types of BOTS so in this case
we've got the bot that plays GTA but
also like reddit bots and discord BOTS
chat BOTS all kinds of you know
competitive BOTS that you know compete
against each other in games and so on
there's just an endless
number of things that you can do in
Python so that's kind of what I suggest
so let's get through the basics first
also I think if you want to learn to
program well you have to kind of have
have three things you need to know you
know what programming actually is you
need to have a toolset to some degree so
learning like syntax and stuff like that
is kind of your tool set and then you
need to know how to put those things
together and actually use your tools but
if you want to actually start making
stuff in Python you don't need a big
toolset so it's kind of like if you want
to start working on cars you know you're
not going to go and spend 20 or 30
thousand dollars on a bunch of tools and
the biggest tool chest that you can find
in like a lift for your car you don't
need to do that you just need to spend
you know you need a few basic tools and
that's it and the same thing is true
with programming you you really don't
need to know that much to start
producing some pretty incredible things
and those basic things are like if
statements functions for and Wow loops
but arguably you could get away with
like just using a while loop right like
you can do a whole lot of things and you
can pretty much do anything with like
five basic principles so anyways the
other thing that I just want to bring up
before we get too deep into Python is
comparing Python to other languages so
you know should you learn Python or
should you learn C or Java or JavaScript
or like all these other million
languages I personally am a big fan of
Python just because of the rapid way you
can develop things like you can make
stuff in Python unbelievably fast and
usually the only downside you might hear
about Python is you know one it's it's a
beginner is language well I mean I guess
it is a beginners language but you can
do anything in Python that other people
are doing in any other language so I
wouldn't let them tell you that you know
you can't do certain things like I I do
contracting consulting work and I
frequently get tried to or I frequently
get attempted to be hired anyway
I frequently have hiring attempts on me
to to do like machine learning stuff and
you know are like artificial
intelligence stuff and like web
development data analysis this kind of
stuff like huge companies are
using Python so to call it a beginner's
only language or something is it's
pretty silly also people call Python
slow this is true and false at the same
time native Python is indeed very slow
and but Python and practice is not slow
Python in practice you're using things
like numpy and like other packages that
you'll find as you progress in python
that are actually just like python
wrappers around you guessed it C or C++
code so it's actually very fast and it's
me it's gonna be faster than any C or
C++ that you or I or 99.99% of us would
ever write so anyway Python and practice
is also very fast in my opinion it is
the best language you could possibly
learn so anyways let's get into it I
know some people are gonna say you spent
too long blabbing on and my argument to
that is if you do if that information
was unuseful to you I strongly suggest
you just go to like you could go to the
documentation and go to like Python 3
Docs and then just go to the tutorial
here and this just runs through all the
things like so if you just want to just
jump into Python maybe you already know
a language or whatever come here go
through this tutorial here because
chances are you can just zoom through it
if that's what you really want to do go
for it so check that out and also even
if you want to continue with the video
series save that you you should come
back to this from time to time like
sometimes I'll go through here and all
like relook at this stuff and there'll
be stuff that like I totally forgot
existed like I'll learn new things and
stuff like that so definitely don't
forget that this exists like the the
pythons you know core website and their
documentation is pretty darn good so
don't don't forget about it anyway let's
go ahead and get Python I thought I hit
back but I guess I didn't so so let's go
to downloads and you could hit 3/7 right
here so yes I'm on a Windows machine a
lot of people will be like ah
why not Linux it just doesn't matter
use whatever operating system
you want to use it just does not matter
so yes I'm on Windows and so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna look I'm on a
64-bit version of Windows
I believe the default gives you 32 bit
which I wish it didn't because your with
32-bit you're limited to 2 gigabytes of
RAM which is kind of silly mm-hmm now
why let's see if maybe I'll click 3 7 1
here scroll down right so I want the you
know AMD 64 executable installer
obviously if you're on a 32-bit version
of Windows go ahead and get that one but
if you have 64-bit go ahead and keep
using 64-bit also Python on Windows is
just traditionally one of the more
difficult ones to get around certain
errors so it'll be a little more useful
for me to show people how to get around
them so install it launcher will go
ahead and also check this box to add
Python to your path and then you could
customize the installation but I'm just
gonna go ahead and install it now and
that's fun so we'll wait for that and
then when we're done once you have the
programming language you need something
that's called like an IDE it's a
interactive development environment
basically actually the eye is for
integrated and this is just where you
write your code so this is your your
interpreter sometimes or usually it kind
of doubles as a place for you to write
your code then also interpret the code
and run it and all that you can use
either the one that comes with Python
which is idle just IDL II I used to use
that a lot I'm a big fan of very simple
editors I'm also going to disable this
path length limit here I really like
simple editors I like that they don't
give you much of a crutch the my problem
with idle is it crashes sometimes like
especially if you do like a bulk like
edit undo or something
and it crashes it didn't autosave and
you lost all your work also it doesn't
have a dark theme I do preferred now
especially to work with like darker
themes so at least to my knowledge I
actually I think at some point it
actually did get a dark theme anyway I
eventually switched to sublime text
I'm also going to grab sublime text and
I want sublime text 3 at some point I do
actually have a license for sublime text
you don't need a license you can
continue to use it forever for free so
I'm gonna grab windows 64-bit here and
grab sublime text and I'll show you guys
how you can set up sublime text second
it's super simple we just have to pick
what you know what with what do we want
to run our scripts because you can use
sublime text to write all you know
basically any language so I'll hit yes
here next install don't finish there I'm
surprised I didn't throw anything on my
desktop let's see if we there sublime
text 3 I'm gonna go ahead and pull it
down here oh you're not gonna let me do
that huh I should be able to add it
there I'll figure that out later anyways
so this is like our editor and we can
write pretty much whatever we wanted in
here the next thing I'm gonna do is I'm
just gonna go quickly to file save as
and I'm just gonna save it to the
desktop because that's where we're gonna
work for now and I'm gonna call this
pi/3 tutorial dot I and I'll try to
remember it in the future but as you
progress in Python never name your
Python program the same thing as like
what you're ever going to import any
package you intend to use and all that
probably doesn't mean much to you right
now but good to keep that in mind
immediately so go ahead and hit save
there so now at least a blind text knows
it's a Python file I'm gonna zoom in a
little bit I'm gonna hold ctrl and roll
my mouse wheel so it makes it nice and
big for the so it's easy to see on the
video and now we're just gonna do one of
the most basic things in Python and that
is a print so print and this is what's
used typically for debugging purposes so
as you're running your your program it's
just going to output
- the little console a bit of
information whatever you ask it - so for
now we'll use a string so a string is
just encased by quotes like this so can
either be like double quotes or you
could encase it in single quotes you
could even get pretty fancy and encase
it in triple quotes so anyway more on
triple quotes later but for now let's
just print hello universe everybody
likes to say hello world I'll prefer the
universe so now to run generally you'll
do ctrl + B but it's gonna want to know
what do you want to run it with
initially and we're gonna run it with
Python here so I'm just going to choose
Python and then you can see down here
the output and so it just says hello
universe so that is our very first
Python program super super basic but
from here what we're gonna do is get
into some of the more you know basic
principles and tools that you'll need to
actually write programs that are gonna
actually do things for you back whenever
I first started to learn to program
I thought all programs were these
graphical user interfaces and I thought
I was always waiting for the moment for
the like the thing to pop up and it was
gonna be a window and stuff I didn't
ever really realize that actually most
programs just kind of operate in the
background you don't really see them
doing anything they're just kind of
running but you don't see them running
so anyways that was always kind of weird
to me when I first started to learn so
if you guys have any questions or
comments concerns whatever feel free to
leave them below also I've quick shout
out to my most recent channel members
Alfonso papasan EC Hayes and Scott Davis
thank you guys very much for your
support
if you don't know what channel members
channel membership is you can click that
like blue join button there and it's
just a way to support the Creator you
get access to videos early among some
other things like chat emotes in like a
little badge next to your name and stuff
basically it's it's more so a way just
to support the creators so if you want
to do that that is how
anyway that's all for now in the next
tutorial we're going to be getting a
little deeper into some more cool kind
of logical things with programming so
stay tuned for that and I will see you
guys in the next video